tulsi gabbard is a former presidential
candidate and former congresswoman of
hawaii
so tell us
it takes some gall
to tell americans we're going to create
a new
new world order after the last one
globalization
wrecked our jobs and
kind of was responsible for the rise of
china do you think he's going to get
away with this
well jesse i think it's important that
we look at what's happening right in
front of us right i mean
i i when i look at these issues when i
look at policies i i look at it by
thinking of what is actually going to
improve the lives of the american people
what will make their lives better more
secure more prosperous more fulfilled
and unfortunately what we've seen is
that president biden isn't doing that he
should be focused on his job as
president of the united states of
america and actually solving the
problems that we're facing here securing
the border making our communities more
safe improving education strengthening
our economy by supporting small business
there are a lot of problems unfortunate
that need to be fixed that's where he
should be focused but instead as we've
seen
he seems to be more focused on trying to
be president of the world and along with
the power elite of america taking this
missionary zeal to say you know what
we're going to set aside the problems
that the american people are facing and
instead focus on saving the world by
spreading democracy
everywhere it's just a bigger version of
obama's arab spring where he took his
kind of messianic attitude towards
trying to save the middle east by
spreading democracy but really just left
destruction suffering and death in his
wake and and the american people paid a
very very heavy uh price for that
it's about humility isn't it tulsi it's
about recognizing that the american
president can't just shape the world
however he wants
and
part of being intelligent is kind of
knowing your limitations do you think
joe biden knows his limitations or do
you think he's so arrogant that he think
he's just gonna you know create
a new world order with global alliances
that will be run out of washington and
brussels like usual
central to that humility jesse is first
and foremost recognizing you're not god
you are not in control and if you try to
pretend that you are
what will result even with good
intentions what will result
unfortunately
is more suffering more hardship for the
people in the world that supposedly he's
trying to save
but also for the american people because
joe biden's already told us hey freedom
is not free
you the american people are going to pay
the price
and that's exactly that is exactly what
we will see play out if he continues to
think that he is and can be somehow the
controller of all people and all things
in this world
i mean he can barely even control
himself let alone the entire world tulsi
gabbard thank you so much for your
analysis thanks jesse hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else